26 x 31 - 403 / 13 x 31 +13
et il en l'île de la réunion 974 autres
mais comment fait-il
attendez y ait encore de noël ne partez
pas si vous pouviez la prochaine fois
plutôt que me donner le numéro de la
réunion que donnent les résultats du
tiercé dans l'ordre par exemple
arrangerait les plaques
901 4 3 et 25 et vous cherchez 553
allez-y jean marc sens plus 404 moins 25
79 9 +1 10 montre 7,7 fois 60 1953
comment fait-il
pas rapides attaquants rapides à
25 7 75 2 9 et 5
ses remarques
945 moi c'est 38
75 me 38 37 25 mois deux ou trois par
trois maisons 51
ensuite j'ai pu être effacés
c'est vrai pour moi mounir ils seront 45
- 7 38
j'ai été surpris par le 25 moins de
vingt-trois voilà on y est bien moins
canaux et toujours ce aux frais par la
rapidité de deux ans mardi
jean-marc vous nous répondez
si vous le souhaitez vous n'était pas
non plus complètement vous dévoiler et
comment vous faites pour trouver aussi
rapidement sire que là c'est pas facile
dénoncez vous y allez au fur et à mesure
oui pilote chasse et se trouvait
à
bonbons et simple
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que ça donne sur ce dernier
coup de chiffres votre résultat laurent
ou très très loin 854 jean-marc je suis
tombé dessus vous l'avez on veut le voir
3 +14 1 4 possède 28 28 parties 168 plus
560 creuse ou du pied pour son pays
natal des images etc c'est remarquable
qui va se passer magnifique à
faire bien jouer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non non c'est ok non ça marche je
compte est bon de les oublier allez-y
sept mois 4 3 75 / 3 25 à 3 1 200 + 22
cents à 1 ou 2 par huit attention ce oui
t'invite
du
format semblait presque gêné de la va
retrouver ce bon compte on tient qu'à
vous jean marc
et pas être gêné 656 x 24 / 192 plus 456
moins 346 / 8
mai j'ai embarqué veut dire 24 oui
oui oui
parce qu'il ya une opération qui fait
peur enfin qu'il faut simplifier ainsi
156 x 24 / on va pas faire x 24 192 ses
huit fois 24 donc on va directement / 8
rassurez-moi jean-marc vous n'avez pas
fait 6 156 x 24 égale 15 1744 non vous
simplifier le flanc peuvent donc 656 / 8
ha on est à 80 2 600 / 8,75 et 50,6 et
par 8 7 après ça ça allait tout seul 456
moins 346 et 110 +192 +82 nous sommes à
192 et on revient à 192 / 8 dont 24 en
un hiver ce bond qui faisait peur mais
apparemment pas jean-marc oui non mais
ça c'est pas et c'est pas une première
un pur pour jean marc hein c'est rare
que les comptes lui il lui fasse peur
non mais simplement jean-marc on
aimerait comprendre parce que on joue
tous avec grand plaisir toutes celles et
ceux qui nous regardent et également et
aimerait bien avoir la petite astuce
comme ça pour je sais pas il des choses
à savoir en priorité d'aider visibilité
je ne sais pas il ya un petit truc oui
il ya bien un truc plus que 8 mai
qu'elle a acquis peu l'habitude de
talent il va parler jean marc et avait
livré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thierry je fais
résultat peut-être jean marc lecomte
bout on y va c'était 3 10 cents -1 99
par 1990 - 75015 oui très bien ouais
et là en plus je regardais un peu les
deux équipes jouent et j'ai vu jean marc
mais il a trouvé une vitesse mais très
rapidement une pression en moins de 5
secondes après que ce soit fiché les
points les dix points supplémentaires et
la nette avance pour le moment l'équipe
de l'équipe de jean marc et d'hervé 812
moins 33 / 19 + 6 x 13 + 203
814 oui bonne réponse jean-marc
7 10 2 1 6 7
oui jean-marc 7 + 7 14
14 - 2 12 oui
12 soit
6,72 wii dispose à 9 72 x
9148 très bien bravo
8 10 10 25 100 et 50
sans marque 100 / 25 4 oui il faut dit
ce sont mille fois 50 caps ont jusqu à 4
404 mosson 304
ch
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bruno 3,90 euros seulement le compte est
bon allez-y la marque deux fois 6 12 par
4 48% une 43 par 9 387 ou au citron 180
bravo
c'est le meilleur des meilleurs en
chiffres jean marc il a cette réputation
philippe y en a pas beaucoup de meilleur
que lui
elle va d'ailleurs il l'a fait il a fait
comme renardeau de l'agglo mais l'egypte
est remplacé dans l'île il a l'air
d'être chaud
en tout cas on cherche quelqu'un qui
serait meilleur que jean bart et pour
l'instant c'est si compliqué
[Musique]